My name is Ashe.
我叫阿什。
I'm from Houston, Texas.
我来自德克萨斯州休斯顿。
How I met your mother means comfort to me.
我遇见你母亲对我来说意味着安慰。
2009 I lost my very young mom, 37 years old, to a very rare form of cancer.
2009 年，我 37 岁的母亲因一种非常罕见的癌症去世了。
And in turn I lost everyone that I called family.
反过来，我失去了所有我称之为家人的人。
So 20 year old me, very lost, very confused, and very alone had this show.
所以20岁的我，非常失落，非常困惑，非常孤独地度过了这个节目。
Being able to connect with characters and feel a comfort.
能够与角色产生联系并感到舒适。
that I hadn't felt since my mom had been around, meant so much to me and really did help me grow as a person.
自从我妈妈在身边以来，我从未有过这种感觉，这对我来说意义重大，并且确实帮助我成长为一个人。
I've carried this show with me throughout my adulthood.
我整个成年时期都带着这个节目。
Now I am 36 and it really means a lot.
现在我36岁了，这真的意义重大。
I actually got a chance to see one of Josh's shows in Houston a few years back, which was also very comforting and brought that same feeling back.
事实上，几年前我有机会在休斯敦观看了乔什的一场演出，这也非常令人欣慰，并带回了同样的感觉。
I'm so grateful that you're doing this podcast and I am entirely grateful for how I met your mother.
我非常感谢你做这个播客，我也非常感谢我如何认识你的母亲。
I'm alone, all be soon.
我一个人，一切都快点吧。
You're New York City, when I see you.
当我看到你时，你是纽约市。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我告诉你纽约市的一切。
Well, hello out there listeners and watchers and fans of how I met your mother.
好吧，各位听众、观察者和粉丝们，你们好，我是如何认识你们母亲的。
Welcome to How We Made Your Mother, I'm Josh Radner.
欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》，我是乔什·拉德纳。
I played Ted Mosby for nine seasons on How I Met Your Mother.
我在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中扮演泰德·莫斯比九季。
I am joined by my friend Craig Thomas who co-created the show with Carter Bays.
我的朋友克雷格·托马斯也加入了我的行列，他与卡特·贝斯共同创作了这个节目。
Hi Craig.
嗨克雷格。
Hey Josh.
嘿乔什。
How's it going?
怎么样了？
I, every time Alec, you make me cry with these openings of the show.
我，每次亚历克，你都会让我在节目的开场时哭泣。
What a beautiful story.
多么美丽的故事啊。
Thank you, Ash.
谢谢你，阿什。
Thank you for sharing that with us.
感谢您与我们分享。
I think when you're in, when you're in grief and something makes you laugh or someone makes you laugh, you almost always forget it.
我认为，当你陷入悲伤时，当某事让你发笑或某人让你发笑时，你几乎总是会忘记它。
There's something about the, so anything that can, I don't know, alleviate a kind of heavy moment with some lightheartedness.
这是有道理的，所以我不知道有什么可以用轻松的心情来缓解沉重的时刻。
You feel grateful and loyal to that thing forever.
你永远对那件事感到感激和忠诚。
That sounds like what we were able to provide for her.
这听起来像是我们能够为她提供的。
Yeah, it's amazing.
是的，太棒了。
I mean, I can't imagine how hard that was to at such a young age to go through that.
我的意思是，我无法想象在这么年轻的时候经历这些是多么困难。
If the show provided comfort, it's amazing.
如果这部剧能给人带来安慰，那就太棒了。
It's amazing that seems like she's almost the age now that her mother was, if I was tracking that correctly.
令人惊讶的是，如果我没记错的话，她现在的年龄似乎已经接近她母亲的年龄了。
So for the show to have meant that to her, and now she's an adult and at that age, and like that it's still part of her life, Thank you so much today.
所以这部剧对她来说意味着这一点，现在她已经是成年人了，在那个年龄，而且它仍然是她生活的一部分，今天非常感谢。
That is very much was our greatest hope in making this show that it would reach somebody like you Ash and at the moment you needed it.
这是我们制作这个节目的最大希望，希望它能在你需要它的时候惠及像阿什这样的人。
Thank you for letting us know that.
感谢您让我们知道这一点。
I mean, that is the greatest gift just to know that.
我的意思是，知道这一点就是最好的礼物。
And if anyone has other stories they'd like to share about what how I met your mother means to them or something funny or, you know, it can be anything, please go to how we meet your mother.com, go to contact and write us a note, drop us a voice note.
如果有人有其他故事想分享关于我如何遇见你母亲对他们意味着什么，或者有趣的事情，或者，你知道，可以是任何事情，请访问我们如何遇见你母亲.com，联系我们并给我们写一条便条，给我们发语音留言。
we're always happy to hear from people, because that's why we're doing this show.
我们总是很高兴收到人们的来信，因为这就是我们做这个节目的原因。
And today, speaking of the show, we are talking about, I would call this a season one classic, nothing good happens after two a.m.
今天，说到这部剧，我们正在谈论，我将其称为第一季的经典，凌晨两点后没有什么好事发生。
I would also say, Jordana, obviously my wife, she had never seen the show, but when I said it's called nothing good happens after two a.m.
我还要说，乔丹娜，显然是我的妻子，她从来没有看过这个节目，但是当我说这叫做凌晨两点之后就没有什么好事发生了。
She says, I know that phrase, like I think it's one of those phrases.
她说，我知道那个短语，就像我认为它是其中一个短语一样。
That's happening now.
现在正在发生这种情况。
Yeah, that's how things are getting out there and boomeranging back at us and people are like, That's a phrase, and it's like, actually, I think it's, because of our stuff.
是的，事情就是这样出现的，然后又回到我们身边，人们会说，这是一个短语，实际上，我认为是因为我们的东西。
We might have invented that phrase.
我们可能发明了这个短语。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, Courtney Kang's mother, Courtney Kang, one of our writers' mother would say that to Courtney Kang and that it made it on how much a mother.
是的，考特尼·康的母亲，考特尼·康，我们的一位作家的母亲会对考特尼·康说这句话，这取决于母亲的程度。
So maybe that was a phrase that Courtney Kang's mother was about not going back.
所以也许这就是 Courtney Kang 母亲不想再回头的一句话。
At least in the Kang household.
至少在康家是这样。
At least in the Kang household, it was a famous saying.
至少在康家，这是一句名言。
Yeah, but it does feel like now it's one of those things maybe it's sticky because you don't have to live long live long to have proven the truth of it.
是的，但现在确实感觉它是其中之一，也许它很粘，因为你不必活得很长才能证明它的真相。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yes, like we've all had that thing at like 2.30 or 3, and you're like, why am I here?
是的，就像我们都在 2.30 或 3 点经历过那样的事情，你会想，我为什么在这里？
This is where bad things happen.
这就是坏事发生的地方。
This is the hour where dark things happen.
这是黑暗事情发生的时刻。
The decisions aren't getting better from here on out.
从现在开始，这些决定并没有变得更好。
There's no upward trend at this point.
目前还没有上升趋势。
Yeah, and I love that feeling in this episode, that feeling of immediate ominousness.
是的，我喜欢这一集里的那种感觉，那种立即不祥的感觉。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Future Ted telling his kids this law of physics, love the universe, nothing good happens after 2am, and the whole episode, you know immediately it's going to go bad.
未来的泰德告诉他的孩子们这个物理定律，热爱宇宙，凌晨两点之后不会有什么好事发生，而整个情节，你立刻就知道它会变坏。
It's like a disaster movie.
这就像一部灾难片。
Like you know there's going to be a tornado, there's going to be an earthquake, like something bad is going to happen and it does, and I sort of love that about this one.
就像你知道将会有龙卷风，将会发生地震，就像会发生一些不好的事情一样，而且它确实发生了，我有点喜欢这个。
Remember I told you that thing of if you were a character in a movie, what would people be screaming at you to do or not do?
还记得我告诉过你，如果你是电影中的角色，人们会尖叫着让你做什么或不做什么吗？
Yes.
是的。
And you have this chorus, especially Marshall and Lily, Barney seems a little more encouraging, they're like, they know this is a bad idea.
你们有这个合唱，尤其是马歇尔和莉莉，巴尼似乎更鼓舞人心，他们就像，他们知道这是一个坏主意。
Please don't go over there.
请不要去那里。
Um, so let's just, let's just set the scene, set some context for this episode.
嗯，让我们来设置场景，为这一集设置一些背景。
Alec, when did this episode air?
亚历克，这一集什么时候播出？
It's aired on April 10th, 2006.
该剧于2006年4月10日播出。
April 10th, 2006.
2006 年 4 月 10 日。
Okay.
好的。
And, uh, Craig, give us the, uh, kind of, uh, synopsis of, and, and start us at the end of, uh, life among the gorillas, because that's really where this episode gets, uh, teed up and kicked off.
而且，呃，克雷格，给我们，呃，呃，呃，概要，然后，从……呃，大猩猩生活的结尾开始，因为这确实是这一集的开始，呃，准备和开始。
Can I just note that the episode before before this came out on March 20th.
我想提醒一下，之前的剧集是 3 月 20 日播出的。
So you had 20 days.
所以你有20天的时间。
It was a big gap, which is funny because when I watched this last night with my wife and like, I said, we never did those previously things.
这是一个很大的差距，这很有趣，因为当我昨晚和我的妻子一起看这个时，我说，我们从来没有做过那些以前的事情。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
The previously is baked into the episode on this one.
之前的内容已融入到这一集中。
So basically the narrative is like, here's what happened or, you know, I just previously on how much of other basically.
所以基本上的叙述就像，这就是发生的事情，或者，你知道，我之前基本上讲过多少其他的事情。
And it was because of that, I said to her, I think there was probably several weeks of ways from that one Monday to the next and it was a cliffhanger.
正因为如此，我对她说，我认为从那个星期一到下一个星期一可能有几周的时间，这是一个悬念。
But isn't it funny, like in 2006, we somewhat still had attention spans and collective cultural memory that we do not have now.
但这不是很有趣吗，就像2006年一样，我们在某种程度上仍然拥有现在所没有的注意力广度和集体文化记忆。
Like it's been so eroded at this point.
就好像此时已经被侵蚀殆尽一样。
Like if it's on the next day, you have to be like previously.
就像如果是第二天，你必须像以前一样。
Here's what happened.
事情是这样的。
Yeah, they remind you.
是的，他们提醒你了。
I know you've forgotten, yeah.
我知道你已经忘记了，是的。
So yeah, that was funny to see that.
是的，看到这一点很有趣。
I think it's maybe the only time in the series we kind of quite baked it in that over me.
我想这可能是这个系列中唯一一次我们把它放在我身上。
Like you need a reminder audience of what happened.
就像你需要提醒观众发生了什么一样。
But the cliffhanger at the end of life among the gorillas is that Ted is waiting late at night to get a call from Victoria who's in Germany on many hours ahead of him the next day.
但大猩猩生命最后时刻的悬念是，特德在深夜等待维多利亚的电话，而维多利亚第二天比他早几个小时就到了德国。
And the film rings and it's not Victoria who he thinks is calling him to break up with him.
电影响起，他认为打电话给他分手的并不是维多利亚。
It is in fact Robin who is inviting him over at about two in the morning.
事实上，是罗宾在凌晨两点左右邀请他过来的。
And the episode takes off from there.
这一集就从那里开始。
It's the dilemma of what do you do?
这是你做什么的困境？
What do you do with this?
你用这个做什么？
You think you're breaking up with your Rhonda's relationship and the girl you're kind of secretly you're not so secretly in love with calls you over two in the morning.
你以为你要和朗达的关系分手，而你暗恋的那个女孩在凌晨两点多给你打电话。
And that is this episode.
这就是这一集。
Yeah.
是的。
What, these phones that they had, did they have caller ID, like no one- I kept wondering that.
他们拥有的这些手机有什么来电显示功能，就像没有人一样——我一直想知道这一点。
No one knows who's calling.
没有人知道是谁打来的电话。
Everyone just answers the phone like it's like a- Totally.
每个人都只是接电话，就像——完全一样。
A landline, you know?
固定电话，你知道吗？
Yeah, and if I did- it's a crucial plot point in this, is that Robin would answer the phone not seeing that it was Ted's phone lighting up with Victoria's name because it's not a smartphone, it's 2006, it's a flip phone.
是的，如果我这么做了——这就是一个关键的情节点，罗宾会接电话，而没有看到这是特德的手机，上面写着维多利亚的名字，因为它不是智能手机，它是 2006 年的，它是翻盖手机。
I think you just opened the phone and answered it.
我想你刚刚打开电话并接听了。
some point flip phones or you could see, right?
或者你可以看到一些翻盖手机，对吧？
At some point, I'm looking at you, like, you remember this, I don't know why you're the expert in this, but I think there was a, there's a little glass thing on the front that you could see, but this is also back in the day when people were answering phone calls, like no one's doing that now.
在某些时候，我看着你，就像，你还记得这一点，我不知道为什么你是这方面的专家，但我认为前面有一个小玻璃东西，你可以看到，但这也是在人们接听电话的日子里，就像现在没有人这样做一样。
Like no one's, it's like, it's like an etiquette breach to call people, it's like, what are you doing?
不像任何人，打电话给别人就像违反礼仪，就像，你在做什么？
It's an incredible invasion of privacy to call someone with a texting person.
给正在发短信的人打电话是对隐私的令人难以置信的侵犯。
people who just call on each other and not know any of the fucks cuts of the wild west.
人们只是互相打电话，却不知道狂野西部的任何细节。
Well, that's the focus crucial plot points in this are related to that.
嗯，这就是重点，关键情节点与此相关。
And it does feel like a ticket dated, but you need to make the buy.
它确实感觉像是一张注明日期的门票，但你需要购买。
My favorite thing about that.
我最喜欢的是这一点。
Here's my two favorite things about this episode.
这是本集我最喜欢的两件事。
And the first one will sound like I'm criticizing.
第一个听起来像是我在批评。
But we've Carter and I wrote this one, by the way, the brilliant Carter Bay is.
但是我们卡特和我写了这篇文章，顺便说一句，卡特湾非常出色。
I feel like Carter did excellent excellent work on this one.
我觉得卡特在这方面做得非常出色。
I feel like maybe he started this one off and then I kind of counter or punched it a bit, really brilliant writing.
我觉得也许他一开始就写了这篇文章，然后我有点反驳或打了它一下，真是精彩的写作。
I love how it's kind of all in largely in real time.
我喜欢它在很大程度上是实时的。
It has that really urgent feeling of like, it's all happening late at night.
它有一种非常紧迫的感觉，就像这一切都发生在深夜。
It feels late at night.
感觉已经是深夜了。
It feels like you're dizzy and drunk on the lateness of the night and the ominousness of what may happen.
感觉就像你在深夜和可能发生的不祥的事情中感到头晕和喝醉。
I really like that vibe.
我真的很喜欢那种氛围。
My first comment on that episode is, I love how few jokes there are in it.
我对该集的第一条评论是，我喜欢其中的笑话很少。
Yeah.
是的。
That's a really weird compliment.
这真是一个奇怪的赞美。
I mean it as a compliment because it is daringly and defiantly un-jokey, and I really like that.
我的意思是这是一种赞美，因为它是大胆的、挑衅的、不开玩笑的，我真的很喜欢这一点。
I really like it because it is a play this one.
我真的很喜欢它，因为它是一部戏剧。
This is a theater, you're acting in this episode, Josh, is A, superb and B, theater acting.
这是一个剧院，你在这一集里表演，乔什，是 A，精湛，B，戏剧表演。
I mean that in the best possible way.
我的意思是，以最好的方式。
You are acting a drama in this episode in the best way.
你在这一集中以最好的方式表演了一场戏剧。
Well, it's also like, it's theatrical in like almost a classic sense.
嗯，它也就像，它几乎是一种经典意义上的戏剧。
It's like, there's a ghost in this episode.
就好像这一集中有一个鬼魂。
It's like- That's my thing too, you stole my thing too.
就像——那也是我的东西，你也偷了我的东西。
My thing too, my second comment is, it's a fucking ghost story.
我也是，我的第二条评论是，这真是一个鬼故事。
Yeah.
是的。
This episode's so great because it's a ghost story.
这一集太棒了，因为它是一个鬼故事。
How great is Ashley at playing that ghost version of Victoria, this kind of Victoria, the kind of different.
阿什利（Ashley）非常擅长扮演幽灵版的维多利亚，这种不同的维多利亚。
I was blown away by how great the two of you were in those scenes, truly great.
我对你们两个在那些场景中的出色表现感到震惊，真的很棒。
It's Hamlet, it's Our Town.
这是哈姆雷特，这是我们的小镇。
We're tapping into the theatricality of the ghost character.
我们正在挖掘鬼魂角色的戏剧性。
The whole episode is the ghost.
整个情节都是鬼魂。
What episode is this, 18?
这是第几集，18？
18, that's 22.
18，就是22。
So you're 18 episodes in and you've established a kind of rapport with the audience.
到了 18 集，你已经与观众建立了一种融洽的关系。
characters are so sharply etched and defined at this point.
在这一点上，人物的刻画和定义是如此清晰。
The the the on again off the the love story or almost love story of Ted and Robin is so firmly established.
泰德和罗宾的爱情故事或近乎爱情的故事是如此牢固地建立起来。
Yeah.
是的。
And you I think you guys have done a masterful job of turning Robin's affections toward Ted very gradually very gradually to the point where she kind of can't you know and he's it's just such a great thing especially for like a love avoidant, like Robin, she can't, because she can't have Ted, her, her affections get amplified so much, right?
你们我认为你们已经做得非常出色了，逐渐非常逐渐地将罗宾对泰德的感情转变到她有点无法知道的地步，而他是一件很棒的事情，特别是对于像罗宾这样的爱情回避者来说，她不能，因为她不能让泰德，她，她的感情被放大这么多，对吗？
But you've really narratively just pulled back the bow.
但你实际上只是在叙事上拉开了弓。
It's so taught at the end of guerrillas.
游击队最后就是这么教的。
So when you let it fly in this episode, it doesn't need jokes because it's also, the stakes are quite high.
所以当你在这一集中让它飞起来时，它不需要笑话，因为它的风险也相当高。
The stakes are higher in this episode, I would argue than any other episode in the first season.
我认为这一集的赌注比第一季的任何其他集都更高。
I think one of the things that Marshall and Lily are scared about is they realize that this friend group is pretty special they like Robin they like having Robin around yes they've really grown accustomed to having her around and Ted and Robin are threatening this this ecosystem they're threatening yes the kind of petri dish they're all living in which is interesting too because like Marshall and Lily kind of go from wanting Ted and Robin to get together to not wanting that in this episode because it will be built on a lie and the foundation of of this relationship being built on kind of this crime that Lily calls it.
我认为马歇尔和莉莉担心的一件事是，他们意识到这个朋友群体非常特别，他们喜欢罗宾，他们喜欢罗宾在身边，是的，他们已经习惯了有她在身边，泰德和罗宾正在威胁这个生态系统，他们正在威胁，是的，他们都生活在那种培养皿中，这也很有趣，因为像马歇尔和莉莉一样，在这一集里，从希望泰德和罗宾在一起变成了不希望这样，因为它将建立在谎言和这种关系的基础是建立在莉莉所说的这种犯罪之上的。
She's like, don't start it this way, right?
她说，不要这样开始，对吧？
If you guys are going to become that couple that we sit on that front porch with in the future and grow old with and we'll all be couple best friends forever, it can't be built on like this really messy moment after that two in the morning.
如果你们将来要成为我们坐在前廊上一起变老的情侣，我们都将永远是最好的朋友，那么就不能像凌晨两点之后的这个非常混乱的时刻那样建立起来。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了送你去纽约。
will be right back and now back to the show.
马上回来，现在回到演出​​。
Did you by any chance, I just read this yesterday and I know I referenced an Atlantic article in the last episode, you're gonna know what my reading habits are.
你有没有机会，我昨天刚读到这篇文章，我知道我在上一集中引用了一篇大西洋文章，你会知道我的阅读习惯是什么。
But there's an article in the Atlantic.
但《大西洋月刊》上有一篇文章。
Aren't they one of our sponsors?
他们不是我们的赞助商之一吗？
No way, that's me on these.
没办法，这就是我。
Sorry, I confused them as the Atlantic with me on these.
抱歉，我在这些问题上将它们与我混淆为大西洋。
But the Atlantic, they have an article about how the Simpsons is essentially a moral show.
但是《大西洋月刊》有一篇文章介绍《辛普森一家》本质上是一部道德剧。
Like it's moral center is very strong.
就像它的道德中心非常强大一样。
I totally agree.
我完全同意。
Back in the day remember when bush one said we need we need a culture much more like the Waltons than the Simpsons And it was considered like because because Bart was like disrespecting and he was an underachiever We we thought it was leading to moral collapse not we but you know what I mean like this kind of so But they said like the Simpsons is essentially like if you if you really track it It's got like a really strong moral center And I would argue that how I met your mother has a really strong moral center in that You know, Lilly also often functions as the moral conscience of the show.
记得那天，布什一号说我们需要一种更像沃尔顿一家而不是辛普森一家的文化，这被认为是因为巴特不尊重人，他是一个成绩不佳的人我们认为这会导致道德崩溃，不是我们，但你知道我的意思，所以但他们说辛普森一家本质上就像如果你真的跟踪它它有一个非常强大的道德中心我认为我如何认识你母亲有一个非常强大的道德中心要知道，莉莉也经常充当节目的道德良心。
Yeah, right.
是的，对。
She's, she's often the one saying like, you can't do this, like, this is wrong, like, this is going to, but I, but I agree that there, but I, I wonder, was that something you guys ever discussed in the, or is that just an outgrowth of you and Carter being generally like good people, like, you know what I'm saying, or, or is that something TV has to be moral?
她，她经常说，你不能这样做，就像，这是错误的，就像，这是会做的，但我，但我同意，但我，我想知道，这是你们曾经讨论过的事情，还是只是你和卡特一般都是好人的结果，比如，你知道我在说什么，或者，或者这是电视必须有道德的东西吗？
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yeah, I do, I do, I think we wanted, I mean, thank you for that, that's very nice.
是的，我愿意，我愿意，我想我们想要，我的意思是，谢谢你，这非常好。
And yeah, I think we're people, here's the thing, here's what I think we're aiming at, to know that to show out a moral core, but to still show these characters doing the wrong thing sometimes.
是的，我认为我们是人，这就是事情，这就是我认为我们的目标，知道要表现出道德核心，但仍然要表现出这些角色有时会做错误的事情。
Especially Ted, who is so winning and charming and he's so open-hearted and wants, but he's still a guy, he's still a guy who has these feelings for this beautiful woman who has called him in the morning.
尤其是泰德，他是如此的迷人，如此的迷人，如此的开放和想要，但他仍然是一个男人，他仍然是一个对这个早上给他打电话的美丽女人有这些感情的男人。
So I'd say like, yes, a moral center from Future Ted telling, from moment one, even from the ending of the previous episode, Future Ted's kind of saying buckle up, your old man fucked up here a little bit.
所以我想说，是的，未来泰德的道德中心告诉我们，从一开始，甚至从上一集的结尾开始，未来泰德就在说，系好安全带，你的老人在这里搞砸了一点。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, it just occurred to me the very convention of him telling his kids, like when we tell our kids stories, we're trying to impose, we're trying to impart some moral lesson.
嗯，我刚刚想到了他告诉他的孩子们的惯例，就像我们给孩子们讲故事一样，我们试图强加，我们试图传授一些道德教训。
That's the moral part.
这是道德部分。
That's the moral part is kind of Future Ted looking back going like, this wasn't me at my best.
这就是道德部分，就像未来的泰德回顾过去一样，这不是我最好的状态。
If I can spare you this in your life, listen to your old man right now.
如果我能让你在你的生活中免受这种痛苦，现在就听你老人家的话吧。
Yes, because I still don't feel good about this.
是的，因为我对此仍然感觉不太好。
These things that you tell yourself are okay at two in the morning, you may not feel that way even 25 years hence, yeah.
凌晨两点你告诉自己的这些事情没问题，即使 25 年后你可能也不会这么想了，是的。
You know, it occurs to me also, Ted has a break glass in case of emergency catchphrase that seems to grant him permission to do whatever he wants and it's, but it's Robin.
你知道，我也想到，泰德有一个在紧急情况下打碎玻璃的标语，这似乎允许他做任何他想做的事，但这是罗宾。
Like, whenever he says it's Robin.
就像，每当他说是罗宾时。
Yeah, you murdered a man, but for Rob, I did it.
是的，你谋杀了一个人，但为了罗布，我做到了。
But it was a hitchhiker, Ted, it had nothing to do with Robin.
但这是搭便车的人，特德，与罗宾无关。
You just hit a guy.
你刚刚打了一个人。
But Robin, no, it's really true.
但是罗宾，不，这是真的。
Now, when you got this script, did you feel like his, like, Ted is all of a sudden in this crime movie at two in the morning, in this episode?
现在，当你拿到这个剧本时，你是否觉得他的，就像，特德突然出现在这部凌晨两点的犯罪电影中，在这一集中？
Like, this is like a different Ted, a different tone.
就像，这就像一个不同的特德，不同的语气。
What did you think when you read this one, were you at all like, ooh, this is messy for Ted?
当你读到这篇文章时，你有什么想法？你是否觉得，哦，这对特德来说太混乱了？
Are we like, who cool?
我们就像，谁很酷？
This is juicy for Ted.
这对特德来说很有趣。
This is, I get to do some good acting here.
这就是，我可以在这里做一些好的表演。
Oh no, no, I was thinking for as an actor, you're like, this is gold.
哦不，不，我在想，作为一名演员，你会想，这是金子。
I'm never, I have a long running argument with my dad and I don't know if I've shared about this, but it's worth sharing.
我从来没有和我爸爸争论过很长时间，我不知道我是否分享过这件事，但它值得分享。
I've had, I mean, there's been a decades long argument with my dad.
我的意思是，我和我父亲的争论已经持续了几十年。
My dad watches things and he's a big consumer of TV.
我爸爸看东西，他是电视的大消费者。
He loves TV, but he also watches everything through this like pretty strict moral lens where he'll finish like 75% of the things he finishes you up.
他喜欢电视，但他也通过这个非常严格的道德镜头来观察一切，他会完成他完成你的事情的 75%。
Why did they screw up their lives so bad?
为什么他们把自己的生活搞得这么糟糕？
Why do people make these choices that screw up their lives so bad?
为什么人们会做出这些让他们的生活变得如此糟糕的选择？
And I always say, so you could have a TV show to watch.
我总是说，这样你就可以看电视节目了。
That's not super fucking boring.
这不是超级无聊。
Yeah.
是的。
I said, do you want to watch people make the right decisions all the time?
我说，你想看着人们一直做出正确的决定吗？
Like there's no story.
就像没有故事一样。
Like we tell stories about fatal flaws, about hubris, about this is when I really stepped in it.
就像我们讲述致命缺陷、傲慢的故事一样，这就是我真正介入的时候。
We like to watch people get tangled enough so we can watch them untangle.
我们喜欢看到人们纠缠不清，这样我们就可以看着他们解开纠缠。
That story is conflict, right?
那个故事是冲突的，对吧？
That is it.
就是这样。
Yeah.
是的。
So when I, as an actor, you're looking for, oh, wow, this puts me in this ties this character and not.
所以当我，作为一名演员，你在寻找，哦，哇，这让我与这个角色联系在一起，而不是。
It's like, this is going to be really fun to play because he's to play, you know, two different things that are pulling you in two totally different directions.
就像，这玩起来真的很有趣，因为他要玩，你知道，两种不同的东西会把你拉向两个完全不同的方向。
I mean, it's really a war with his, uh, it's his ego and his, and his super ego and his id kind of hashing it out.
我的意思是，这确实是一场与他的战争，呃，这是他的自我和他的，以及他的超级自我和他的本我之间的冲突。
You know, he's, he's really at war with himself and the specter or the ghost of Victoria is just his own conscience spinning this, uh, apparition to be in front of him to play the other side out.
你知道，他，他真的在与自己交战，而维多利亚的幽灵或鬼魂只是他自己的良心，在他面前旋转这个，呃，幽灵来玩弄另一方。
Yeah.
是的。
It's almost future him and two, Victoria's future him and Lily's kind of future him and there's like three future tabs kind of in his episode being like put on the brakes buddy and he can't quite do it.
这几乎是未来的他和两个，维多利亚的未来的他和莉莉的未来的他，在他的剧集中有三个未来的标签，就像踩刹车，伙计，他不能完全做到这一点。
He tries.
他尝试了。
He really does try at a certain moment to do it any episode, which I also really liked, right and that one that right before they can, he really tries to say goodbye, I love that.
他确实在某个时刻尝试做任何一集，我也很喜欢，对，就在他们可以之前，他真的试图说再见，我喜欢这一点。
I love that moment where you try to pull out of the nose dive.
我喜欢你试图摆脱急转直下的那一刻。
But it's also so true, there's that, okay, I should go and then there's the hug, which doesn't break.
但这也是如此，那就是，好吧，我应该走了，然后就是拥抱，这个拥抱不会破裂。
And then there's like, are we trying to pull out of the hug?
然后我们就会想，我们是否想摆脱拥抱？
Oh no, our cheek are brushing against each other.
哦不，我们的脸颊在互相摩擦。
I guess I'll go, oh no, we're kissing.
我想我会走了，哦不，我们正在接吻。
Like, there was something so great about the choreography, it was so, you know, so recognizable.
就像，编舞有一些很棒的东西，它是如此，你知道，如此容易辨认。
What disgusting thing did she whisper in your air right before that take?
就在拍摄之前，她在你的空中低语了什么令人厌恶的话？
I don't know if Coby said she always did it.
我不知道科比是否说过她总是这样做。
Yeah, I don't think we were at that because I think that started when they started doing it.
是的，我认为我们还没有做到这一点，因为我认为当他们开始这样做时就开始了。
When they were in bed and had the couple thing go in.
当他们躺在床上，把情侣的东西放进去的时候。
Maybe even Coby was like, I don't know him well enough to drop the scat humor I'm going to drop later.
也许连科比都会说，我对他还不够了解，无法放弃我稍后要放弃的幽默。
You built to that.
你就是为此而建的。
You built to that, which makes sense.
您为此而构建，这是有道理的。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
Now, I really felt that electricity and your performance here, her too.
现在，我真的感受到了电力和你在这里的表演，她也是。
I mean, like too, you've been like, you're following Ted out there from Manhattan to Brooklyn.
我的意思是，你也跟着特德从曼哈顿到布鲁克林。
It's like you're witnessing, there's this real feeling of like, he's in trouble, he's transressing.
就好像你正在目睹，有一种真实的感觉，他遇到了麻烦，他正在变性。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
You've got a bag full of produce.
你有一个装满农产品的袋子。
Yeah, the juicing is so funny.
是的，榨汁太有趣了。
But you know that, I think Jordana kind of responded when he said park slope and pointed out like the Upper West Side to Park Slope is a real journey.
但你知道，我认为乔丹娜在谈到公园坡并指出从上西区到公园坡是一次真正的旅程时做出了回应。
It is.
这是。
It's not 15 minutes.
还不到15分钟。
It's got a lot of time to think about it.
有很多时间去思考。
It's a lot, even late at night, that's still gonna be like, is that it like a 40 minute?
很多，即使是在深夜，仍然会这样，是不是 40 分钟？
I'd say solid 35, 40 minutes.
我想说35、40分钟。
Yeah, it's a 35, 40 minute ride.
是的，车程 35、40 分钟。
So he has a lot of time to fantasize.
所以他有大把的时间去幻想。
And then he has to switch cabs because the cab driver is drinking.
然后他不得不换出租车，因为出租车司机喝酒了。
But I felt the electricity in your performance.
但我感受到了你表演中的电力。
I could tell like, you were into it.
我看得出来，你很喜欢它。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
You knew this was like, this was a juicy one.
你知道这就像，这是一个多汁的。
And I thought that would be your answer that you'd be like, no, I saw this was juicy.
我想这就是你的答案，你会说，不，我看到这很有趣。
It was almost like, um, it was almost like as a theater actor, which at that time, I still considered myself mostly a theater actor.
这几乎就像，嗯，这几乎就像作为一名戏剧演员，当时，我仍然认为自己主要是一名戏剧演员。
That was where most of my hours as an actor were on stage, not in front of the camera.
那是我作为演员的大部分时间都在舞台上，而不是在镜头前的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
But there was something so, and I think it's significant that, you know, Carter was late to Wesleyan, right?
但有一些事情是这样的，我认为这很重要，你知道，卡特迟到了卫斯理安，对吧？
Cause he had won like the young playwriting conference and he had an off-Broadway production of a play in New York City when he was 17 or 18, right?
因为他像青年剧作家会议一样赢得了胜利，并且在他 17 或 18 岁时就在纽约市制作了一部非百老汇戏剧，对吧？
It's true.
这是真的。
And there was always something, and maybe that's why I got the role, or some sort of, I always felt like you're guys writing, this one in particular really could have been a play.
总有一些事情，也许这就是为什么我得到这个角色，或者某种原因，我总觉得你们在写，特别是这个真的可以是一部戏剧。
And I approached it, I think, as a play, you know?
我想，我把它当作一场戏剧来对待，你知道吗？
This scene in the bathroom with Victoria and Ted felt the most kind of like a scene in a play.
维多利亚和泰德在浴室里的这一幕感觉最像戏剧中的场景。
Yes.
是的。
And it's true, you guys didn't, you didn't have a, I mean, you cut back to Marshall and Lillian Barney, which I now realize if we're really following this through, they're the Greek chorus, right?
确实，你们没有，我的意思是，你们切回马歇尔和莉莲·巴尼，我现在意识到，如果我们真的遵循这一点，他们就是希腊合唱团，对吧？
Like they're the, they don't really have a story going.
就像他们一样，他们并没有真正的故事。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
They're really there for 10 minutes.
他们真的在那里呆了10分钟。
I mean, Korean Elvis.
我是说，韩国猫王。
Korean Elvis is amazing.
韩国猫王真是太棒了。
But like they, they really are there.
但就像他们一样，他们确实存在。
It's all, everybody's on one track, basically, right?
就这样，基本上每个人都在一条轨道上，对吧？
They're, it's, it is like theater and that like, there's no B story.
他们是，它是，就像戏剧一样，没有B故事。
Carter always talks about that.
卡特总是谈论这个。
He's, he was always a great voice of like, Let's not be slavish to B stories and C stories.
他总是发出这样的声音：“我们不要成为 B 类故事和 C 类故事的奴隶。”
Let's, some episodes are the A story and everything is about, everyone's weighing in on that.
让我们来说，有些情节是一个故事，一切都是关于这个，每个人都在权衡这一点。
Everyone's, especially in these ones that take place in kind of in real time.
每个人，尤其是那些实时发生的事情。
And so much, so many great hymnium episodes are like that.
很多很多伟大的赞美诗片段都是这样的。
Carter was a great, he was a religious devotee to a, let's make it one thing.
卡特是一位伟大的人，他是一位宗教信徒，让我们把它变成一件事。
I mean, not every episode, is that not every great hymnium episode?
我的意思是，不是每一集，这不是每一集伟大的赞美诗吗？
Is that it's good to mix it up?
混在一起就好了吗？
But to be able to do that speed is great.
但能够做到这样的速度已经很棒了。
It's two things.
这是两件事。
one, when you're telling a story to your kids, it's like, it is kind of strange when you go, meanwhile, over here, there was this unrelated thing was happening, which doesn't actually have that much bearing.
第一，当你给你的孩子讲故事时，感觉有点奇怪，同时，在这里，发生了一些不相关的事情，这实际上并没有多大影响。
But we talked about this earlier, but like, when there's an event, like, nothing good happens after 2am, no other thing is going to be a missable.
但我们之前讨论过这一点，但是就像，当有一个事件发生时，就像，凌晨 2 点之后没有什么好事发生，没有其他事情会被错过。
It's the thing.
就是这个事情。
Yeah.
是的。
I love how the episodes, I love going back to to Robin's day, like showing how she got in this pretty fragile, vulnerable, somewhat needy place where she was like, I need this guy to come over right now.
我喜欢这些情节，我喜欢回到罗宾的时代，比如展示她如何进入这个非常脆弱、脆弱、有点需要的地方，她就像，我现在需要这个人过来。
Yeah, I really liked that.
是的，我真的很喜欢那个。
Here's 20 hours earlier.
这里是 20 小时前。
And like, yeah, it felt very cinematic that moment.
就像，是的，那一刻感觉非常电影化。
It feels more like a play or a movie this episode than a second episode, which I love.
这集感觉更像是一部戏剧或电影，而不是我喜欢的第二集。
And I love meaning Sandy Rivers, by the way, just we got to give a shout out to Alexis Denisov.
顺便说一句，我喜欢桑迪·里弗斯（Sandy Rivers），我们必须向亚历克西斯·杰尼索夫（Alexis Denisov）大声喊叫。
Yeah.
是的。
Unbelievable introduction to Sandy Rivers.
对桑迪河的令人难以置信的介绍。
But there was, you guys didn't go to this well all that often, but every time you did, I thought it was hilarious, which is her kindergarten class.
不过还有，你们不常去这个井，但是每次去我都觉得很好笑，这是她幼儿园的课。
Yes.
是的。
So funny.
太有趣了。
Always funny.
总是很有趣。
Are you a lesbian?
你是女同性恋吗？
So funny.
太有趣了。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And then also Barney, like, you know, just being like, we're not going to talk about my job.
还有巴尼，你知道，我们不会谈论我的工作。
We're going to do magic.
我们要变魔术。
And he crushes.
他压碎了。
Yeah.
是的。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
I remember just sit there like dying inside about her own identity watching him kill in front of these kids.
我记得我只是坐在那儿，看着他在这些孩子面前杀人，心里对自己的身份感到快要死了。
Yeah, her having this horrible soul-searching day, including being hit on by Alison Haddigan's husband, not in real life, but the character he played, Alexis Enesoff, who is the nicest dude in the world, and lean into the playing, this smarmy asshole character so hard, because he's the nicest guy in the world, and knew he could do this.
是的，她经历了这个可怕的自我反省的日子，包括被艾莉森·哈迪根的丈夫搭讪，不是在现实生活中，而是他扮演的角色亚历克西斯·埃内索夫，他是世界上最好的家伙，并且努力地扮演这个狡猾的混蛋角色，因为他是世界上最好的人，并且知道他可以做到这一点。
Also, it should be noted, that's his real hair.
另外，应该指出的是，那是他的真发。
Yeah, that's a wonderful- That's his real hair, just his hair.
是的，那太棒了——那是他真正的头发，只是他的头发。
His hair- His hair- Totally his castard out.
他的头发——他的头发——完全脱光了。
So not who he is in real life, but he really enjoyed it.
所以不是现实生活中的他，但他真的很享受。
Do you know what was funny when I was watching Alexis, who I just, it's like I hadn't forgotten how good he is, but there's so much pleasure in watching.
你知道当我看亚历克西斯时有什么有趣的吗，我只是，好像我没有忘记他有多出色，但观看时有很多乐趣。
Yeah, he has, he does this weird thing, which Neil does a lot, which is like, it's an incredibly kind of broad character at once, but it's also subtle.
是的，他做了这种奇怪的事情，尼尔经常这样做，这就像，这是一个令人难以置信的广泛角色，但它也很微妙。
He's doing something very subtle.
他正在做一些非常微妙的事情。
He's always subtle too, it's really true.
他也总是很微妙，这是真的。
But the way he was just kind of listening to her, like on the phone, and the way he was kind of, The nonchalance, which he, he, he suggests that they should have sex with each other.
但他只是听她说话，就像在电话里一样，还有他那种漠不关心的态度，他、他、他建议他们应该发生性关系。
I love so much, how he said, having sex is fun.
我非常喜欢，他说，做爱很有趣。
Having sex is fun.
做爱很有趣。
So funny.
太有趣了。
So good.
超好的。
Allison always says to him, it's sort of like a compliment to both his looks and his acting.
艾莉森总是对他说，这有点像是对他的外表和表演的赞美。
She's like, he's a leading man, you know, he's a character actor, trapped in a leading man body.
她就像，他是一个男主角，你知道，他是一个性格演员，被困在男主角的身体里。
Like he's so, he's a good looking dude, but so capable of leaning into that character, he's stuffed to, while maintaining kind of a groundedness, he's a, I am a huge fan of the show, Angel, which he was brilliant on Alexis was, and it was so we were thrilled to get him on the show.
就像他一样，他是一个好看的家伙，但很有能力融入这个角色，他很充实，同时保持一种脚踏实地，他是一个，我是这个节目的超级粉丝，天使，他在亚历克西斯身上表现得很出色，所以我们很高兴让他参加这个节目。
I also, I remember that Alexis, and he did a bunch of episodes as Sandy Rivers, but he never didn't kill.
我还记得亚历克西斯，他演了很多集桑迪·里弗斯，但他从来没有杀人过。
It was just murderous row, it was, it was all killer no feller.
这只是一场凶残的争吵，是的，这全都是杀手，不是坏人。
It was like table read, run through for the crew.
这就像为机组人员朗读的表格。
It was like, he had it literally like a perfect score of just crushing every single time.
就好像，他每一次都获得了完美的成绩。
He just inhabited it so well.
他只是生活得很好。
It's funny, sometimes there are, we took a clown class at NYU and it's kind of like, it was like finding what your clown is and your clown might not be goofy, your clown might be arrogant, your clown might be a blowhard, you know what I'm saying?
很有趣，有时，我们在纽约大学参加了小丑课程，这有点像，就像找到你的小丑是什么，你的小丑可能并不傻，你的小丑可能很傲慢，你的小丑可能是个吹牛大王，你知道我在说什么吗？
And it feels like Sandy Rivers is like Alexis's clown or one of his clowns, it was just something that he did so effortlessly and it looked like, It looked like he just knew how to be Sandy Rivers, like from the moment he came on.
感觉桑迪·里弗斯就像亚历克西斯的小丑或他的小丑之一，这只是他毫不费力地做的事情，看起来，看起来他就知道如何成为桑迪·里弗斯，就像从他上场的那一刻起一样。
He could have that could have been a whole whole TV show like if there was a TV show about if that if you if like new Metro News one was a TV show he would have been like the Barney of the Metro News one TV.
他本来可以是一整套电视节目，就像有一个电视节目一样，如果你像《新都市新闻》那样是一部电视节目，他就会像《都市新闻》电视中的巴尼一样。
I mean just like Frazier Crane in Cheers or something where you know like now he was unbelievable.
我的意思是，就像《干杯》中的弗雷泽·克莱恩（Frazier Crane）一样，或者你现在知道的其他东西，他令人难以置信。
So that's our second hymium significant other two episodes in a row right left on the grill is was Taran and now Alexis is in this one and and there will be more yeah we're keeping we're keeping an account.
所以这是我们的第二次赞美，烤架上左边连续两集是塔兰，现在亚历克西斯在这一集中，而且还会有更多，是的，我们正在保留我们正在保留的帐户。
So a lot of times you would go in for, you know, you go in for these fittings, you know, on a Monday after the table reader or Tuesday after the run through, they asked to see you and you try on a ton of clothes and they just pick.
所以很多时候你会去，你知道，你去试穿这些试穿，你知道，在读表后的周一或浏览完后的周二，他们要求见你，你试穿一大堆衣服，他们就会挑选。
And a lot of times, you know, Jason and I, the biggest bonding Jason and I did for nine years was we would often stay in the same jeans and just swap out our shirts or sweaters, but we would change on set because we didn't walk back to our dressing room, right?
很多时候，你知道，杰森和我，杰森和我九年来最大的联系就是我们经常穿着同一条牛仔裤，然后换掉衬衫或毛衣，但我们会在片场换衣服，因为我们没有走回更衣室，对吧？
So we were constantly just shirtless talking about things, you know.
所以我们经常光着膀子谈论事情，你知道。
But in this episode, Ted wears the same thing for two episodes straight.
但在这一集中，泰德连续两集都穿着同样的衣服。
So I remember you going with the Casa, and you're like, well, we gotta find something we really like, because you're gonna be in this for two episodes.
所以我记得你和卡萨一起去了，然后你就想，好吧，我们必须找到我们真正喜欢的东西，因为你会在其中出现两集。
And the fact that we landed on that shirt is astonishing to me.
我们穿上那件衬衫的事实让我感到惊讶。
Astonishing.
惊人。
Tell me.
告诉我。
Talk to me about that shirt.
跟我谈谈那件衬衫。
This is not a shirt.
这不是一件衬衫。
I don't know in what, because it's not a shirt I would ever wear in my life, ever, back then or today.
我不知道穿什么，因为这不是我一生中永远不会穿的衬衫，无论是当时还是今天。
But for some reason, I think I, you just, sometimes there's like a weird euphoria in front of the mirror.
但出于某种原因，我想我，你，有时在镜子前会有一种奇怪的欣快感。
Like you put it on the costume design or really likes it, and you're like, yes, right, right?
就像你把它放在服装设计上或者真的很喜欢它，你会说，是的，对吧？
Right?
正确的？
Right.
正确的。
looking at the episode at this exact moment.
此时此刻正在看这一集。
I don't even know.
我什至不知道。
It almost feels like the Tim Robinson thing of like the patterns.
感觉就像蒂姆·罗宾逊（Tim Robinson）那样的图案。
Remember the pattern shirt?
还记得那件图案衬衫吗？
What's Dan Flash?
丹·闪光是什么？
Dan Flash is a pattern shirt.
Dan Flash 是一款图案衬衫。
That's what it feels like.
就是这样的感觉。
Long enough, you'd devolve into madness.
时间长了，你就会陷入疯狂。
Well, it was softened a little bit when he had the blazer on.
嗯，当他穿上西装外套时，它变得柔和了一些。
I will say that.
我会这么说。
I was delighted to hear my friend Rachel Yamagata's song.
我很高兴听到我的朋友 Rachel Yamagata 的歌曲。
That song is so...
那首歌是如此...
Sorry, I think that's the song.
抱歉，我想这就是这首歌。
Were you friends at that point or did you become friends because we used your music on the show, how did that happen?
你们当时是朋友还是因为我们在节目中使用了你的音乐而成为朋友，这是怎么发生的？
No, I think we were friends.
不，我想我们是朋友。
So I became friends with Rachel because my friend Amy went to college with her manager.
所以我和雷切尔成了朋友，因为我的朋友艾米和她的经理一起上大学。
So we started going to her shows and Rachel and I became friends.
所以我们开始去看她的演出，雷切尔和我成了朋友。
And now we're really good friends.
现在我们真的是好朋友了。
You might have recommended that we use that song.
您可能建议我们使用那首歌。
That song is, I think you did.
那首歌是，我想你做到了。
I think I did.
我想我做到了。
I will take credit for it.
我会因此而获得功劳。
You did, and it's coming back to me.
你做到了，它又回到了我的身边。
And that boy, I was watching it last night and I said, how beautiful is that song?
还有那个男孩，我昨晚看的时候我说，那首歌多美啊？
I mean, it just sets that tone of that perfect song because it's a waltz and it's got this like undercurrent of late night sadness to it.
我的意思是，它只是为那首完美的歌曲奠定了基调，因为它是一首华尔兹，并且有深夜悲伤的暗流。
Late night sadness and it feels, yeah, that's it.
深夜的悲伤，感觉，是的，就是这样。
It feels sort of sleepy and sad, but a little dizzy.
感觉有点困和悲伤，但有点头晕。
Like there's something about it that was the perfect moment to perfectly landed where Robin got to as she made that phone call to tell.
就好像有什么事情是完美的时刻，完美地落在了罗宾打电话告诉她的地方。
That was our big challenge.
这是我们面临的巨大挑战。
How do you make the sale that she would choose that night to call him and that was what that act of that episode, that 20 hours earlier tried to do.
你如何才能说服她那天晚上会选择给他打电话，而这正是 20 小时前那一集的行为所试图做的。
And also little touches like how the enormous glass of wine she pours herself, you know?
还有一些小细节，比如她如何给自己倒一大杯酒，你知道吗？
Like there's just something.
就像有什么东西一样。
Yeah.
是的。
We get into those nights where you just feel particularly self-pitying and lonely.
我们会进入那些让你感到特别自怜和孤独的夜晚。
Yeah, and it's again, like that two in the morning thing of like, I'll always feel this way.
是的，又是这样，就像凌晨两点一样，我总会有这种感觉。
Yeah.
是的。
You can very easily convince yourself at two in the morning that I will always feel like this.
你可以很容易地在凌晨两点说服自己，我会一直有这样的感觉。
The 20s are you don't have enough experience having gotten through those nights.
二十几岁是你没有足够的经验来度过那些夜晚。
Yes.
是的。
So those nights when they come feel the dark night of the soul is particularly dark.
所以那些夜晚来临的时候感觉灵魂的暗夜特别的黑暗。
Agree.
同意。
And I think you haven't seen enough of those through to remember what the other side feels like.
我认为你还没有看够这些，无法记住对方的感受。
Yeah.
是的。
So you make bad decisions sometimes.
所以有时你会做出错误的决定。
Yeah.
是的。
And you think, yeah, you chase things that maybe you shouldn't.
然后你想，是的，你追逐了也许你不应该追求的东西。
And she's chasing something too.
而她也在追寻着什么。
She knows Ted's still with Victoria at that point until he lies and says he isn't, which he needed to sort of make the whole story work, which boy, re-watching that moment, that's a big old liar right there from Ted.
她知道泰德当时还和维多利亚在一起，直到他撒谎说他已经不在了，他需要这样做才能让整个故事顺利进行，哪个男孩，重看那一刻，那是泰德的一个大骗子。
And he thinks it's a lie, the ends justify the means, the ends are I'm going to marry Robin and this will just all come out in the wash.
他认为这是一个谎言，目的证明手段是正当的，目的是我要嫁给罗宾，而这一切都会水落石出。
And boy, it does not work out that way at that moment.
天哪，那一刻事情并非如此。
Well, it almost also feels like I'm gonna break up Victoria in six hours, so what's the harm in changing around the timeline a little bit?
好吧，感觉就像我要在六个小时内分手维多利亚一样，那么稍微改变一下时间线有什么坏处呢？
Arguing the semantics, the way we argue the semantics of things to tour advantage, and then sometimes Karma goes, nope.
争论语义，我们争论事物语义的方式是为了获得优势，然后有时因果报应，不。
Right.
正确的。
It doesn't always, but sometimes it does, and that isn't how Ted and Robin were meant to to begin, and it is 2 p.m.
并不总是如此，但有时确实如此，而这并不是泰德和罗宾本来应该如何开始的，现在是下午 2 点。
He musted me, fell in love with you, knew who you were sitting.
他强迫我，爱上你，知道你坐在谁的身边。
And now, commercials!
现在，广告！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们还解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
they know that's not really what's going on.
他们知道事实并非如此。
But they jump into it with such gusto that two of them come in the morning.
但他们都非常热情地投入其中，以至于早上就有两个人来了。
And she comes over with like, she got a lot of stuff at the late night.
她过来时说，她在深夜得到了很多东西。
You got a lot of stuff at the Bodega.
你在酒窖里有很多东西。
Yeah.
是的。
That can't be like the best quality.
这不可能是最好的品质。
Yeah.
是的。
And she's like, once I'm lying and it's just so funny.
她说，一旦我撒谎了，那真是太有趣了。
They abandoned the juicing immediately.
他们立即放弃了榨汁。
Will juice and what does he say to, we're juicing his friends to the cow driver.
威尔榨汁，他对什么说，我们正在给牛司机榨汁他的朋友。
We're juicing his friends.
我们正在给他的朋友们榨汁。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
I love future narrator Ted's presence in this one where just every so often he'll just be like, go to bed.
我喜欢未来的叙述者泰德在这部电影中的出现，他时常会说，去睡觉吧。
It's like he's watching it with us.
就好像他和我们一起看一样。
He's like the football announcer like, no, they shouldn't run that play.
他就像足球播音员一样，不，他们不应该播放那场比赛。
Stop it.
停止吧。
Don't do that.
不要那样做。
I also love when Marshall pops in with, it's too late for juice.
我也喜欢马歇尔突然出现，现在喝果汁已经太晚了。
It's too late for juice.
喝果汁已经太晚了。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
It's, you know, I love, there's certain movies like this, too, where you go into the movie knowing all the bad things that are going to happen and the joy is in watching exactly how bad it gets and how badly they unfold.
你知道，我喜欢某些类似这样的电影，你走进电影时就知道将要发生的所有糟糕的事情，而快乐就在于观看事情到底变得有多糟糕以及它们如何糟糕地展开。
This episode is like that, right?
这一集就是这样吧？
This episode is you're going in there, like, no one went into Titanic, like, I wonder what's going to happen to that ship.
这一集是你要去那里，就像，没有人进入泰坦尼克号，就像，我想知道那艘船会发生什么。
This episode is kind of like, the ship's going to sink.
这一集有点像船要沉了。
It's just the details along the way.
这只是沿途的细节。
I mean, in that way, it's both classical theatre, but it's also a bit of a horror film in some ways.
我的意思是，从这个角度来说，它既是古典戏剧，但在某些方面也有点恐怖电影。
late at night, they're scared.
深夜，他们很害怕。
I love the, shout out to John Swahart, our composer, like the really, because we, Rachel, oh my God, it's great, the music placements, that's Andy Gowen and Josh Radner bringing me those songs, Andy Gowen's our music supervisor.
我喜欢，向我们的作曲家约翰·斯瓦哈特大声喊叫，真的，因为我们，雷切尔，天哪，这太棒了，音乐布置，安迪·高文和乔什·拉德纳给我带来了这些歌曲，安迪·高文是我们的音乐总监。
The composer, if you listen to the score, it's very like, there's kind of like a moonlight sonata, kind of like creepy sort of late at night classical, but there's some tone of late at night-ness that is said by that score that is really great.
作曲家，如果你听乐谱的话，它很像，有点像月光奏鸣曲，有点像令人毛骨悚然的深夜古典，但是乐谱里有一些深夜的基调，真的很棒。
So shout out to John Swahart on that one.
因此，请向约翰·斯瓦哈特（John Swahart）大声喊出这一点。
What, I remember Neil and Jason loved, like they get in a fight, right?
什么，我记得尼尔和杰森很喜欢，就像他们打架一样，对吧？
Like they get in a, and they have to scream at each other over that table, right?
就像他们进去了一样，他们必须在桌子上互相尖叫，对吗？
Yeah, I know what you're gonna say.
是的，我知道你要说什么。
I know what line.
我知道什么线。
It's, I'll show you things you've never seen before from Jason.
是的，我将向你展示你从未从杰森身上看到过的东西。
Is that the one you're thinking?
这就是你所想的那个人吗？
Yes, he says that, but I have a different favorite, Jim or Jabber improv that he threw at him a moment, which is, I used to box in the army.
是的，他这么说，但我有一个不同的最爱，吉姆或贾伯即兴表演，他向他扔了一会儿，那就是，我曾经在军队里打过拳击。
Is that is that Neil or Jason Jason Jason both of those in rapid succession the those were his lines, right?
那是尼尔还是杰森·杰森·杰森，这两个人都是他的台词，对吧？
I think he just improvised those For some reason the one I caught was I'll show you things you What's that mean?
我想他只是即兴创作的 出于某种原因，我发现的是我会向你展示一些东西 那是什么意思？
You can find that on on YouTube you can find the full sort out take of just the two of them Yeah, there's also right now take if you look up the bloopers of him and there would Kobe pours that giant bottle of wine and starts drinking it, and she's just drinking it and drinking it, and you hear Pam fry me go.
你可以在YouTube上找到他们两个人的完整剪辑是的，如果你查一下他的花絮，现在还有一个视频，科比倒了一大瓶酒并开始喝它，而她只是喝啊喝，然后你听到帕姆把我炸了。
It goes on, not Kobe, clearly is wondering, when's Pam gonna call cut and Pam just says, I'm just gonna have you drink the whole thing, and she's like, God damn it.
事情还在继续，科比显然在想，帕姆什么时候会打电话叫停，帕姆只是说，我会让你把所有的东西都喝掉，然后她就说，该死的。
It's a very funny, heavy and blooper, you can find it, yeah, everyone was bringing their A game on this one.
这是一款非常有趣、沉重且令人毛骨悚然的游戏，你可以发现它，是的，每个人都在这款游戏中表现出色。
And I also love Barney's kind of side quest, if you will, of like, we're gonna make this night legendary, and I'm gonna disprove this truism from Ted's mom.
我也喜欢巴尼的支线任务，如果你愿意的话，我们会让这个夜晚成为传奇，我会反驳特德妈妈的这个不言而喻的说法。
And I love that they all know Ted's mom sign.
我喜欢他们都知道特德妈妈的标志。
You know what Ted's mom always says.
你知道特德的妈妈总是说的话。
The whole group of friends reframes with that one.
整群朋友都用那个人重新构建。
He's probably, I'm going to prove it wrong.
他可能是，我会证明这是错误的。
That's so many times when Barney wants to stay out and he's like, oh, Mrs. Mosby says, Ted has probably tried to talk Barney out of terrible things.
很多时候，巴尼想要留在外面，他就像，哦，莫斯比夫人说，泰德可能试图说服巴尼不要做可怕的事情。
But with that phrase and I hear Ted is no better than Barney in this moment.
但听了这句话，我听说特德此刻并不比巴尼好。
I mean, it's kind of like Barney's whole meta narrative is he's a magician who pulls it out of the hat at the last moment, right?
我的意思是，这有点像巴尼的整个元叙事，他是一个在最后一刻从帽子里变出来的魔术师，对吧？
Like he's really just, we can turn lead into gold any time if we just decide.
就像他真的很公正一样，只要我们下定决心，我们随时都可以点石成金。
And it doesn't even have to be sex.
而且它甚至不一定是性。
It doesn't have to be exciting.
它不必令人兴奋。
It can be weird.
这可能很奇怪。
Like, Korean Elvis serenading Lily is like good enough.
就像韩国猫王为莉莉唱小夜曲就足够好了。
Licking the Liberty Bell, that's not sexual.
舔自由钟，这不是性行为。
It sounds sexual, but it's not.
听起来很色情，但事实并非如此。
But yeah, I think just it had you have never been done before.
但是，是的，我想这只是你以前从未做过的事情。
He's in search of- New is always better, right?
他在寻找——新的总是更好，对吧？
New is always better.
新的总是更好。
He's in search of the legendary.
他正在寻找传奇。
And sometimes that's women.
有时是女性。
And sometimes it's not.
有时并非如此。
And I really like how I thought of this watching this episode.
我真的很喜欢我在观看这一集时的想法。
The characters are very aware of, the characters are aware they're in a story, in a way.
在某种程度上，角色非常清楚，角色知道他们在故事中。
So the characters react as if they know a future person has re-enlivened that is sort of making them relive the story and they're vaguely aware of the stories happening as it's happening.
因此，角色的反应就好像他们知道未来的人已经复活一样，这让他们重温了故事，并且他们模糊地意识到故事正在发生。
And like Barney is saying, like, you know, there's a freeze frame after Lily kicks Korean Elvis in the nards and freeze frame there, says that would become known as the name, like Lily kicked me and all this much.
就像巴尼说的，就像，你知道，莉莉踢了韩国猫王的甘蔗后有一个定格，然后定格在那里，说这将成为众所周知的名字，就像莉莉踢了我等等。
And immediately you come out of the freeze frame, Barney's like, Hey, guys, remember that time?
一旦你从定格中走出来，巴尼就会说，嘿，伙计们，还记得那次吗？
Lily kicked her, you know, it's the nards have five seconds ago.
莉莉踢了她一脚，你知道，那是五秒钟前的事情。
This idea of like branding things, we will remember this future us will tell this story.
这种想法就像品牌化的东西，我们会记住这个未来我们会讲述这个故事。
Hey, Ted, don't do this.
嘿，特德，别这样做。
You're screwing it up for future you future you if you get with Robin does not want to start your life together on a crime.
如果你和罗宾在一起并不想以犯罪的方式开始你们的生活，那么你的未来就搞砸了。
If there's just this weird kind of meta narrative thing, even the whole show Joe starts with, you know, we're gonna tell, I'm gonna tell my kids about this night.
如果有这种奇怪的元叙事，即使是乔开始的整个节目，你知道，我们会告诉，我会告诉我的孩子们今晚的事。
Like, he, Ted in particular is, and Barney too, are very, they all are.
就像，他，尤其是特德，还有巴尼，非常，他们都是。
You can make the case, they all are, they mythologize their life.
你可以证明这一点，他们都是，他们把自己的生活神话化了。
In the moment.
就在那一刻。
They, Jean Shepherd their life.
他们，让·谢泼德，他们的生命。
They make it, you know, what's that?
他们做到了，你知道，那是什么？
There's that Richard Royal line, or someone said this, if you don't mythologize your life, you'll pathologize your life.
理查德·罗伊尔（Richard Royal）有句话，或者有人说过，如果你不神话化你的生活，你就会使你的生活病理化。
Like, it's actually really, it's really healthy.
就像，它实际上非常非常健康。
to look at your life in this kind of narrative way.
以这种叙述的方式看待你的生活。
So you can also see, if you mythologize your life, if you look at your life narratively, you can see that, I think it's really healthy, like one of the features of depression say, is that you feel like nothing's ever gonna change and nothing's ever gonna, it's static, it's never gonna change.
所以你也可以看到，如果你神话化你的生活，如果你叙述性地审视你的生活，你会发现，我认为这真的很健康，就像抑郁症的特征之一所说的那样，就是你感觉什么都不会改变，也不会改变，它是静态的，永远不会改变。
But if you're in a story, you know that stories are always changing, characters are always growing, characters are always moving through things and getting onto other adventures.
但如果你在一个故事中，你就会知道故事总是在变化，人物总是在成长，人物总是在经历事物并开始其他冒险。
And I think it's actually, you know, we don't want to be grandiose about it, but I think there is something healthy about looking at your life from a narrative context.
我认为实际上，你知道，我们不想对此夸大其词，但我认为从叙事背景来看待你的生活是健康的。
But you have to hover a little over your life to do that.
但你必须在生活中徘徊一段时间才能做到这一点。
I think that's right.
我认为这是对的。
You have to be seeking some kind of meaning or pattern in your life in the moment to even imagine that a meaning and pattern will emerge later.
你必须在当下寻找生活中的某种意义或模式，才能想象稍后会出现某种意义和模式。
Right.
正确的。
I think that's what the show is.
我想这就是这部剧的意义所在。
And the characters are aware of that.
角色们也意识到了这一点。
And it's a little chicken or egg.
这是先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题。
It's like, you can be on the hunt for meaning and pattern, or you can have detected a lot of meaning in patterns, but just honoring that they are there.
就像，你可以寻找意义和模式，或者你可以在模式中发现很多意义，但只是尊重它们的存在。
But even as, and what Ted's doing in this one, he's trying to change the meaning with words in the moment and saying, well, if I'm gonna break up with her tomorrow, it's the same thing as if I already broke up with her, which he doesn't know, that's why she was calling.
但即使如此，特德在这一次中所做的，他也试图用言语改变当时的意思，并说，好吧，如果我明天要和她分手，那就好像我已经和她分手了一样，他不知道，这就是她打电话的原因。
He does not know that.
他不知道这一点。
And he is so rationalizing himself into what he wants in that moment.
在那一刻，他是如此合理化自己想要的东西。
And he's trying to kind of create a different meaning that isn't really the truth and the truth.
他试图创造一种不同的意义，但它并不是真正的真理。
It kind of, there's kind of an organ transplant rejection happens there.
有点，那里发生了器官移植排斥反应。
That's an attempt to turn it into this other narrative.
这是将其转变为另一种叙事的尝试。
And it's like, nope, I'm sorry.
就像，不，对不起。
That's not gonna fit here.
那不适合这里。
I think it's funny how, like Ted takes the juice thing literally in that he goes and buys vegetables.
我认为这很有趣，就像特德从字面上理解果汁一样，他去买蔬菜。
But it's clearly, as we said, it's not about the juice.
但正如我们所说，很明显，这与果汁无关。
Except for Marshall, he's like.
除了马歇尔，他都是这样。
And then she's going to make you some delicious juice, like you're helpless, like you're walking into the lion's den, who could resist that delicious juice.
然后她会给你做一些美味的果汁，就像你无助一样，就像你走进狮子的巢穴，谁能抗拒那美味的果汁。
He's going to lure you in with carrot celery juice.
他会用胡萝卜芹菜汁引诱你。
Yeah.
是的。
And it's funny that Ted buys all this stuff because it goes along with the narrative.
有趣的是，泰德买了所有这些东西，因为它与故事相一致。
He wants to believe that's what's happening.
他想要相信这就是正在发生的事情。
So he's like, if I buy these vegetables, then surely that's the story.
所以他说，如果我买了这些蔬菜，那么故事肯定就是这样的。
It's almost like the vegetables and the fruit are his armor.
蔬菜和水果几乎就是他的盔甲。
Like if I hold these in front of me.
就像我把这些放在我面前一样。
I'm going over here in good faith because she said, let's make some juice, right?
我是真诚地过来的，因为她说，我们来做点果汁吧，对吧？
I will say, just a shout out to Kobe, fantastic bit of acting when he said, when Ted tells Robin, we broke up and she's the smiling while saying the other words, A plus, a plus super star acting.
我要说的是，只是向科比大声喊叫，当他说，当泰德告诉罗宾，我们分手了，她微笑着说其他词时，他的表演太棒了，加上超级明星的表演。
just hilarious and like full of like it's like it's like it's a moment that is electric because you're like there oh this is on but it's also funny but it's also good acting like it's yeah it's yeah I thought the same thing yeah so great I liked when when Ted is on the phone with Lily and Lily's talking some like kind of ethical sense into him I remember I was doing something like like like, damn it, like, which I think I stole from Dustin Hoffman somewhere and could see.
只是很搞笑，就像是一个令人兴奋的时刻，因为你就像在那里哦，这很有趣，但它也表现得很好，就像是的，是的，我认为同样的事情是的，太棒了，我喜欢当特德和莉莉打电话时，莉莉对他谈论某种道德感，我记得我正在做类似，该死的，就像，我想我从达斯汀那里偷来的霍夫曼在某个地方并且可以看到。
Like, there's some sort of like- Good thing to steal from.
就像，有某种类似的东西——可以偷的好东西。
Damn it, like, you know, I really like the, that face is not for her, he's not doing it audibly.
该死的，就像，你知道，我真的很喜欢这张脸，那张脸不适合她，他没有发出声音。
It's just his own internal combustion, you know?
这只是他自己的内燃，你知道吗？
Yeah, I love that moment too.
是的，我也喜欢那一刻。
That is an excellent half of a phone call acting, which of course, you're not really acting with Alison standing at the moment, someone is off screen reading her lines with you and you were very in it in this episode, you were very in the dilemma and I will say, just to defend Ted for a second, he's not just trying to have sex with a pretty girl.
这是电话表演的精彩部分，当然，你现在并不是真的在艾莉森站着的情况下表演，有人在屏幕外和你一起读她的台词，而你在这一集里非常投入，你非常进退两难，我会说，只是为了捍卫特德一秒钟，他不仅仅是想和一个漂亮女孩发生性关系。
He does love Robin, like there is that other side to it.
他确实爱罗宾，就像爱还有另一面一样。
He is imagining something deeper that will come from this.
他正在想象由此产生的更深刻的东西。
This isn't like drunk at McLaren's making out with, yeah, the girl who just got broken up with, yeah.
这不像喝醉了在迈凯伦和那个刚刚分手的女孩亲热，是的。
Barney.
巴尼.
He's not, yeah, he's not being Barney.
他不是，是的，他不是巴尼。
There is some, Ted does not not have a point, if you know what I mean?
有一些，特德并不是没有道理，如果你明白我的意思吗？
There is something there, which is what makes this so interesting of a dilemma, I think.
我认为，有一些东西让这个困境变得如此有趣。
Well, it's also you guys constructed it in such a way that you brought the long distance headache of it to the boiling point where it's like, I can't connect with her, I feel so far away from her.
好吧，也是你们以这样的方式构建了它，使长途头痛达到了沸点，就像，我无法与她联系，我感觉离她很远。
That seed's been planted.
那颗种子已经种下了。
Yeah, it's really, Yeah, it's masterfully constructed to have all of it kind of come to a head and explode in this episode.
是的，真的，是的，它的构造非常巧妙，让所有这些都在这一集中达到高潮并爆炸。
It's engineered, tip of the hat, dramaturgically, to you guys.
对于你们来说，它是精心设计的，戏剧性的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It's a huge shout out to Carter Bay, so I do believe, I feel like this one was more him than me, although I think we both really loved working on this one.
这是对卡特贝的巨大呼声，所以我相信，我觉得这个作品更像是他而不是我，尽管我认为我们都非常喜欢在这个作品上工作。
But the idea of the ghostly Victoria, I feel like that was Carter, because I just remember being so excited about it in a way that makes me feel like it wasn't my idea because it was my idea.
但是幽灵般的维多利亚的想法，我觉得那是卡特的，因为我只记得对此感到非常兴奋，这让我觉得这不是我的想法，因为那是我的想法。
I'm probably like, yeah, it's okay.
我可能会说，是的，没关系。
Rule of writing number one, everything's better with a ghost.
写作第一条规则是，有鬼魂一切都会好起来。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
It just makes it very exciting.
这让它变得非常令人兴奋。
There's a ghost in this episode and you're like, oh, I didn't know that they're doing ghosts on the CBS sitcom at eight o'clock.
这一集中有一个鬼魂，你会想，哦，我不知道他们在八点钟的哥伦比亚广播公司情景喜剧上演鬼魂。
I didn't know we're doing Hamlet here.
我不知道我们要在这里演哈姆雷特。
I'd like to point out that I think I could be wrong.
我想指出的是，我认为我可能是错的。
I think this might be your first right, right after the original right, right?
我想这可能是你的第一个权利，就在原来的权利之后，对吧？
And it's subtle.
而且它很微妙。
It's right as you're getting on top of of Rod, Ted again, Robin, you're kissing, and she says something, can you?
就在你骑在罗德身上的时候，泰德又来了，罗宾，你们在接吻，她说了些什么，可以吗？
I can't believe that we're making it right, right?
我不敢相信我们做对了，对吧？
It's great.
这很棒。
You guys were really electric in that whole thing.
你们在整件事中真的很激动。
It was just like, what's gonna happen?
就像，会发生什么？
It's a suspense episode.
这是一部悬疑剧。
It's a ghost story.
这是一个鬼故事。
It's a little bit of a horror movie, and there's a Korean Elvis.
有点恐怖片的感觉，还有韩国猫王。
It kind of is everything you could ever ask for in 22 minutes of TV, I think.
我想，这就是你在 22 分钟电视节目中所能要求的一切。
I like this one.
我喜欢这个。
I loved when Marshall says, you just got burned Phonics style.
我喜欢马歇尔说的，你只是被拼读风格烧伤了。
Phonics style.
自然拼读风格。
I guarantee you that was Chris or Phil.
我向你保证那是克里斯或菲尔。
That was for you.
那是给你的。
That could be a huge one.
这可能是一个巨大的数字。
It could have been me, but I think it was Lord and Miller.
可能是我，但我认为是洛德和米勒。
Because if that was me, it's just me stealing their verbatim, I think, their vernacular.
因为如果那是我的话，我想，这只是我窃取了他们的原话，他们的白话。
That's a very Chris and Phil shout out to them.
这是克里斯和菲尔对他们大声疾呼的。
When did you guys come up with the kind of ultimate plot point, which is the phone switcheroo?
你们什么时候想到了终极情节点，即电话交换机？
I mean, again, I think technologically, we were like, sometimes that happens because it's 2006.
我的意思是，我认为从技术角度来说，有时会发生这种情况，因为现在是 2006 年。
I think it was how do we, what really undoes Ted here, and it could really only be that, right?
我认为真正让特德崩溃的是我们如何做，而且真的只能是这样，对吧？
I think it was just by process of elimination, like what can, what will destroy everything?
我认为这只是通过消除过程，比如什么可以、什么会摧毁一切？
If Robin hears directly from Victoria, it destroys everything.
如果罗宾直接听到维多利亚的消息，一切都会毁掉。
And we just, I think concocted a way that could happen.
我认为我们只是炮制了一种可能发生的方式。
She's not gonna walk in the door.
她不会走进门的。
She didn't get on a plane from Germany to come surprise Ted at Robin's apartment at him, right?
她从德国坐飞机来罗宾的公寓给泰德一个惊喜，对吧？
It had to be that.
一定是这样。
I think we just got there.
我想我们刚刚到达那里。
But when we got, when watching it last night for the first time in many years, I was, I was delighted by it because I was like surprising, but inevitable.
但是当我们昨晚第一次看到它时，我很高兴，因为我感到惊讶，但又不可避免。
Yep.
是的。
And maybe a little technologically outdated, but, uh, but it works, right?
也许技术上有点过时，但是，呃，但是它有效，对吧？
It works.
有用。
We never said it was in 2006, but when he, when he comes out there and, and she's on the phone and her whole energy is so different.
我们从来没有说过那是在 2006 年，但是当他出来的时候，当她打电话的时候，她的整个能量是如此不同。
And I, you know, I remember, uh, Ben Lee, my, my dear friend, who I used to make music with as Radner and Lee as I'm, it's plugging my other project.
我，你知道，我记得，呃，Ben Lee，我的，我亲爱的朋友，我曾经和拉德纳和李一起制作音乐，就像我一样，它正在插入我的另一个项目。
But he told me that we used to talk about how bad we are or would be at being like bad dudes.
但他告诉我，我们过去常常谈论我们是多么糟糕，或者会像坏人一样。
Like I never wrote this song, but I thought it was kind of like a good line for a country song to say I dance poorly when I dance with the devil.
就像我从来没有写过这首歌一样，但我认为这有点像乡村歌曲中的一句好歌词，说当我与魔鬼共舞时我跳得不好。
Oh, that is a good line.
哦，这是一条好线。
Like my moves don't work when I'm dancing with the devil.
就像当我与魔鬼共舞时我的动作不起作用一样。
And Ben told me, he said, you know, I tried on like the costume of like a dickish rocker for like a couple months.
本告诉我，他说，你知道，我试穿了大约几个月的像一个混蛋摇滚歌手的服装。
And everyone was like, what are you doing?
每个人都说，你在做什么？
You can't do this.
你不能这样做。
But other people who that's their whole brand, they just start off, they do it.
但其他人则认为这就是他们的整个品牌，他们只是开始，然后就这样做了。
And not only do they do it, they seem to get away with it for quite a while, right?
他们不仅这么做了，而且似乎还逍遥法外了很长一段时间，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Yes.
But if you're, if you're constitutionally a nice, kind, thoughtful person, it's going to eat you alive.
但如果你本质上是一个善良、善良、体贴的人，它就会把你活活吃掉。
Karma gets you quicker.
业力让你更快。
Karma gets you much faster and I feel like how many times is Barney like given a false name had a whole false thing and he just seems to get away with it because he never claimed to be anything different whereas Ted actually the ethics does matter to him he does want to be a good guy he is constitutionally honest and when he tries to deceive Victoria and himself on a huge level and Robin, it boomerang so fast back at him.
因果报应让你更快，我觉得有多少次巴尼就像给了一个假名字，做了一件完全错误的事情，他似乎只是侥幸逃脱了，因为他从来没有声称自己有什么不同，而泰德实际上道德对他来说很重要，他确实想成为一个好人，他本质上是诚实的，当他试图在很大程度上欺骗维多利亚和他自己以及罗宾时，它很快就回到了他身上。
It's really true because like Barney, even though there's definitely a heart and soul in there as we've discussed and as we see as the seasons go on, Barney's in the armor building business.
这确实是真的，因为就像巴尼一样，尽管正如我们所讨论的那样，那里肯定有一颗心和灵魂，随着季节的推移，我们看到巴尼正在从事盔甲制造业务。
Barney's building armor starting with that suit and the more bad crap you do, the more you build up your armor I think and when you're the guy that doesn't do the bad stuff and do it once, you get burned and it hits you and there's no armor there and that's kind of what the end of this episode is and why it's why a future into narrator Ted frames the story the way he does.
巴尼从这套衣服开始建造盔甲，你做的越糟糕，我想你的盔甲就越多，当你是那个不做坏事的人，只做了一次，你就会被烧伤，它击中你，那里没有盔甲，这就是这一集的结尾，也是为什么未来的叙述者泰德会像他那样构建故事。
He gets burned.
他被烧伤了。
But that's what I mean though about how I met your mother being a moral or ethical universe where you can't get away with it that long.
但这就是我的意思，尽管我是如何遇见你母亲的，在一个道德或伦理的宇宙中，你无法摆脱它那么久。
There's some sort of come up and for unethical behavior.
出现了某种不道德行为。
By the way, here's another good country song title.
顺便说一下，这是另一首不错的乡村歌曲。
Nothing good happens after 2 a.m.
凌晨两点之后就没有什么好事发生了。
Please somebody write that country song and then send it to us.
请有人写那首乡村歌曲然后发送给我们。
It's a good one.
这是一件好事。
We have reached a point in our show that we like to call questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
我们在节目中已经达到了这样的目的，我们喜欢向一位临床心理学家提出问题和观察，他从未见过我是如何认识你母亲的，而且碰巧与乔什结婚了。
I like this episode because it shows Ted wrestling with a moral dilemma.
我喜欢这一集，因为它展示了泰德与道德困境的斗争。
We get to see is conscience at work.
我们看到良心在起作用。
Lillian Marshall sort of represent the angel on his shoulder, his moral compass, and Barney is, you know, a little more devilish, let's say.
莉莲·马歇尔有点代表了他肩上的天使，他的道德指南针，而巴尼，你知道，可以说，有点邪恶。
And it's interesting to watch Ted stuck in between with Victoria as a literal manifestation of him negotiating between the two parts of himself, the part that just wants to say whatever and be with Robin and feels like the right thing to do is to follow his heart.
有趣的是，看到泰德夹在与维多利亚之间，这实际上是他在自己的两个部分之间进行谈判的表现，其中一部分只想说什么并与罗宾在一起，感觉正确的做法就是跟随自己的内心。
And the part that knows that the right thing to do is to to be honest.
知道正确做法就是诚实的人。
And I just think as an audience member, watching Ted go through this makes him even more multi-dimensional, even more human.
我只是认为作为一名观众，看着特德经历这一切让他变得更加多维，更加人性化。
We all have that devil and angel on our shoulders.
我们每个人的肩膀上都肩负着魔鬼和天使。
It's relatable.
这是有关联的。
And then even further watching him mess up and get burned, that too is relatable.
然后进一步观察他搞砸并被烧伤，这也是有关联的。
So I just think this episode while painful to watch goes a long way in making Ted a character that feels more real to us.
所以我只是认为这一集虽然看起来很痛苦，但它在很大程度上让泰德成为一个让我们感觉更真实的角色。
That's so smart, and that was very much the intention.
这太聪明了，这也是我们的初衷。
And we've said it a couple of times this season, it's really interesting the moments we picked to show that Ted messes up to, and that he's not gonna be giving some amazing speech every week, he's not always going to want the right thing.
这个赛季我们已经说过好几次了，我们选择展示特德搞砸的时刻真的很有趣，他不会每周发表一些精彩的演讲，他并不总是想要正确的事情。
Underneath all of this nefariousness in this episode is something true-hearted and sweet.
在这一集中所有这些邪恶的背后是一些真诚和甜蜜的东西。
At the core of it, Ted really does love Robin, and he really did love her before he ever met Victoria.
从本质上讲，泰德确实爱罗宾，而且在遇到维多利亚之前他确实爱她。
But he's not doing the right thing here, and I do think that humanized the same.
但他在这里没有做正确的事，我确实认为这同样人性化。
I, this is one of my favorite 10 episodes of season one and maybe of the series because of what exactly what Jordan, I couldn't say it better myself.
我，这是第一季我最喜欢的 10 集之一，也许是这个系列的一集，因为乔丹到底是什么，我自己无法说得更好。
That's what makes this one so interesting and it's Ted so human.
这就是为什么这个故事如此有趣，而且泰德如此人性化。
And I feel like your performance in this one, you felt it, you felt excited acting in this episode and I could see more.
我觉得你在这一集中的表演，你感觉到了，你在这一集中的表演感到兴奋，我可以看到更多。
Well, it's also true.
嗯，这也是事实。
Like if I, if someone presents themselves to me as this kind of like infallible kind of exemplar of moral rectitude, I find it actually not only boring, but like quite suspicious, right?
就像如果我，如果有人向我展示自己是这种绝对正确的道德正直的典范，我发现这实际上不仅无聊，而且很可疑，对吧？
I think there's something about, like, piety is very kind of overrated and annoying.
我认为有些事情，比如，虔诚被高估了，而且很烦人。
But if someone presents, hey, I'm vulnerable, I'm flawed, let me tell you three ways I messed up.
但如果有人说，嘿，我很脆弱，我有缺陷，让我告诉你我搞砸的三种方式。
Do you want to connect?
您想连接吗？
Do you want to have a conversation?
您想交谈吗？
Or can I tell you what I learned?
或者我可以告诉你我学到了什么吗？
That is how we solicit kind of, we get people on our team by showing how human we are, not how perfect we are, infallible we are, that all that does is kind of make us turn on ourselves and go, oh, I'm not like this guy, I'm not like this person, right?
这就是我们招揽人才的方式，我们通过展示我们是多么人性化，而不是我们多么完美，我们是多么无误，来让人们加入我们的团队，所有这些所做的一切都是让我们背叛自己，然后说，哦，我不像这个人，我不像这个人，对吧？
But I think also when you're creating a character that you're presumably, we didn't know at at the time, but gonna follow for eight more seasons.
但我认为，当你创造一个可能是我们当时不知道的角色时，我们还会继续关注八季。
You wanna feel like they're, I think that's one of the things I'm most proud of about Ted is that he, while his heart was in the right place, his feet were often pointed in the wrong direction, or his head was going one way, his heart was going another way, his dick was going another way.
你想要感觉他们是，我认为这是我对特德最自豪的事情之一，就是他，虽然他的心在正确的地方，但他的脚经常指向错误的方向，或者他的头朝一个方向，他的心朝另一个方向，他的鸡巴朝另一个方向。
He was a man at odds with himself a lot, But he ultimately learned, he had to learn patience, he had to learn, he had to fail more, he had to struggle.
他是一个经常与自己矛盾的人，但他最终学会了，他必须学会耐心，他必须学习，他必须失败更多，他必须奋斗。
And I would say by that when I started playing Ted, I also had to get a little scuffed up more.
我想说的是，当我开始扮演泰德时，我也不得不变得更加磨损。
And I think we all, I think that's a good thing to teach, whether it's your kids or anyone else you're teaching like, don't bemoan your failures.
我认为我们所有人，我认为这是一件好事，无论是你的孩子还是你所教的其他人，都不要哀叹自己的失败。
Your failures are where your character gets forged.
你的失败是塑造你性格的地方。
Yes.
是的。
You know, and I think that's what he's telling his kids on some level, like your old man really stepped in it in this one.
你知道，我认为这就是他在某种程度上告诉他的孩子们的，就像你的老人真的介入了这件事一样。
Yeah, and he's not hiding it from them.
是的，他并没有向他们隐瞒这一点。
He's not being pious.
他并不虔诚。
He's not being falsely pious.
他并不是假装虔诚。
And he's not hiding it from them.
他并没有向他们隐瞒这一点。
And that should solicit a kind of trust from his kids.
这应该会赢得他的孩子们的某种信任。
Like I'm an honest, you know, both my sisters who I think are wonderful mothers, they apologize to their kids.
就像我是一个诚实的人一样，你知道，我认为我的两个姐妹都是很棒的母亲，她们向自己的孩子道歉。
They say, I screwed up this time or I'm not gonna get everything right.
他们说，我这次搞砸了，否则我不会把一切都做好。
I'm waiting in it.
我在里面等着呢
I'm trying to figure this out as we go.
我正在努力解决这个问题。
So I'm really sorry, I think I misjudged that one.
所以我真的很抱歉，我想我判断错误了。
And I think that's the best thing you can do as a parent.
我认为这是作为父母能做的最好的事情。
That's the best thing you can do.
这是你能做的最好的事情。
That is very much what I tell my nanny to tell my kids.
这就是我告诉我的保姆告诉我的孩子们的。
I don't really spend much time with my kids.
我真的没有花太多时间陪伴我的孩子。
That's a joke.
那是个笑话。
You're dad really screwed up this time.
你爹这次可真是坏透了。
When he's back from his yacht trip, he's going to take you for ice cream.
当他从游艇旅行回来时，他会带你去吃冰淇淋。
No, that's the best thing you can show your kids, that level of honesty, and I'm a human being and I think future Ted's a good dad for doing that, and he may overshare at times, but I do think that showing your kid that you're a human being is huge because then they get to be too, and that's a gift.
不，这是你可以向你的孩子展示的最好的东西，那种程度的诚实，我是一个人，我认为未来的特德是一个这样做的好爸爸，他有时可能会过度分享，但我确实认为向你的孩子展示你是一个人是很重要的，因为这样他们就会成为一个人，这是一份礼物。
Now we've reached the final act of our episode and something we like to do.
现在我们已经到了这一集的最后一幕，也是我们喜欢做的事情。
On this last part of the episode is read one of the many astonishingly beautiful letters that we receive.
在这一集的最后部分，我们读到了我们收到的众多令人惊叹的美丽信件中的一封。
We love these.
我们喜欢这些。
How we made your mother.
我们如何造就了你的母亲。
Yeah, they're so good.
是啊，他们太好了。
So if you would like, again, a reminder, if you'd like to send us a letter, let us know what the show is meant to you, what your relationship is with the show, or you can write us a letter, You can record an audio, but go to how we made your mother.com.
因此，如果您想再次提醒我们，如果您想给我们发一封信，请告诉我们该节目对您来说意味着什么，您与该节目的关系是什么，或者您可以给我们写一封信，您可以录制音频，但请转到我们如何制作您的 mother.com。
Go to contact and follow the instructions there.
前往联系方式并按照那里的说明进行操作。
Should be pretty clear.
应该很清楚了。
Today's letter is from Shiwon.
今天的信是诗源寄来的。
Hi, my name's Shiwon.
嗨，我叫诗媛。
I'm 23 years old and I'm from North Wales, although I'm currently living in London.
我今年 23 岁，来自北威尔士，但目前居住在伦敦。
I've been thinking about what to say here since the podcast came out, but now I have something I really wanna say.
自从播客发布以来，我一直在考虑要在这里说些什么，但现在我有一些我真正想说的话。
Trust the process here.
相信这里的过程。
I don't remember when I first started watching him.
我不记得我第一次看他是什么时候。
They used to air on E4, a British TV channel, when I just started exploring grownup TV for myself.
当我刚刚开始为自己探索成人电视节目时，它们曾经在英国电视频道 E4 上播出。
So I must have been around 9 or 10 years old.
所以我当时应该是9岁或10岁左右。
It's a little young to watch a show, but that's fine.
看节目有点年轻，不过没关系。
But it's safe to say, I don't remember not watching him.
但可以肯定地说，我不记得没有看过他。
For years, I wanted to be a news reporter like Robin, and then I wanted to be a judge like Marshall.
多年来，我想成为像罗宾一样的新闻记者，然后我想成为像马歇尔一样的法官。
Around the time the podcast first came out, I was applying for a master's course in screenwriting.
播客首次推出时，我正在申请编剧硕士学位课程。
I'd been offered an interview and was preparing for it.
我收到了面试机会，并正在为此做准备。
I was listening to the podcast.
我正在听播客。
I heard Josh talk about the Kierkegaard quote about only being able to live your life forwards and a penny dropped.
我听到乔什谈到了克尔凯郭尔的名言：只有一分钱都可以向前迈进。
I can't tell you how much that resonated with me.
我无法告诉你这对我产生了多大的共鸣。
Growing up watching him, yum, call it nature or nurture, I found myself to be a person who looks obsessively for signs from the universe and tries her best to romanticize reality.
看着他长大，嗯，称之为先天或后天培养，我发现自己是一个痴迷于寻找宇宙迹象并尽力将现实浪漫化的人。
I actually used the Kierkegaard, Josh, quote.
我实际上引用了乔什·克尔凯郭尔的名言。
I'm glad I'm getting credited for this quote in my interview.
我很高兴我在采访中引用了这句话。
Thank you, Josh.
谢谢你，乔什。
And I found out today that I got in.
然后今天我发现我进去了。
All right, congrats.
好吧，恭喜。
Masters courses and Danish philosophers aside, Hemium has played a really big role in my life from when I'd watch episodes on E4 to when I began to collect the DVDs at age 12 to now my 20s.
除了硕士课程和丹麦哲学家之外，从我在 E4 上观看剧集，到我 12 岁开始收集 DVD，一直到现在我 20 多岁，Hemium 在我的生活中发挥了非常重要的作用。
I wasn't the happiest of teenagers, but here was this show that taught me to trust the process of my life, to look for signs from the universe and to romanticize everything in my life from the good to the really crappy, because those were the things that shaped my story.
我不是最快乐的青少年，但这个节目教会我相信我的生活过程，寻找宇宙的迹象，并将我生活中的一切浪漫化，从好的到真正糟糕的，因为这些是塑造我的故事的东西。
At my lowest, I'll still go back to find a speech of Ted's to ground me.
在我心情最低落的时候，我仍然会回去寻找特德的演讲来让我站稳脚跟。
And whenever I see a yellow umbrella in the wild, I take it as a sign to keep trusting the process.
每当我在野外看到黄色雨伞时，我都会将其视为继续信任这一过程的标志。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
For a wonderful show that has taught me and so many others that simply, everything will be okay.
这是一场精彩的演出，它教会了我和许多其他人，简单地说，一切都会好起来的。
Thanks for this podcast and its help with master's interviews, love from the other side of the Atlantic Shiwon, aspiring screenwriter, no longer aspiring judge.
感谢这个播客及其对大师采访的帮助，来自大西洋彼岸的爱Shiwon，有抱负的编剧，不再有抱负的法官。
Fantastic.
极好的。
Congratulations.
恭喜。
That's the best.
那是最好的。
I love everything about that.
我喜欢这一切。
Romanticized reality.
浪漫化的现实。
I like that phrase.
我喜欢这句话。
And, you know, it's a lot of what it's a lot of what we were talking about, you know, like, I think to have a show where everything works out and people just keep going from success to success to success feels really dishonest.
而且，你知道，这就是我们谈论的很多内容，你知道，就像，我认为举办一个一切顺利、人们不断从成功到成功再到成功的节目感觉真的很不诚实。
And, and we were trying to, we were trying to make an honest show.
而且，我们正在努力，我们正在努力制作一场诚实的节目。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, a new York City.
我有罪，请装备我，所有的罪孽都被宽恕，一个纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，我们的数字内容制作人（又名 Gen Z Master）是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 HowWeMajormother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to howyougetyourmerch.com.
单击商店链接或访问 howyougetyourmerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my dead father's society also on substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的 Muse Letters，在 CraigThomasRider.com 斜杠小说上订购克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 的处女作，您还可以在 substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the make a difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“有所作为”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下才得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。